Speaker 1: This, by the way, is the thing we tried out. It's an AI voice recording thing, so all of our voices recorded for 30 hours. Just don't be surprised when we use your voice against you. It's really just... What you say absolutely will be used, to open the course of this project. It would help make everything better.
Speaker 2: It's just like that. It's useless from a legal perspective, but it's very useful from a project.
Speaker 1: Yes, he knew. Steve, after we met last time and you said you're an INTJ, I have cloud code hooked up to my Gmail, and I knew I had an email about Myers-Briggs. So I said, can you just find the test, tell me what I am? But I didn't word it perfectly, and so what it did is it said, I reviewed your email style, and I can tell you're an INTJ. Which I knew I was either that or INSJ. And it's like, well, you're analytical, you do this, you do that. I'm an ITJ.
Speaker 3: You are an ITJ.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I knew, I thought I was. I couldn't remember if it was that or, I think I'm a little more sensing, too. But, yeah, the way you were talking reminded me, that's kind of what motivates me, too.
Speaker 3: You've got to be careful and know this about the TJs, because the nickname is total jerks. They're your judgmental.
Speaker 1: I think I learned to suppress that, or hide that. Filter that, probably, whatever the right word is.
Speaker 3: We learn that as we age.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: And I spent 25 years in an old-school data processing shop, where nothing was held back. And so, you adopt that style, and you bring it into a different culture. Allie's working on it, sorry. Amy is supposed to work on the easel for us. All right, go into focus mode. And she's with Jason. Everybody has a water, coffee, coffee stations right downstairs and right by the lobby, help yourself there.
Speaker 3: Lunch should be brought in probably around noon. When lunch is served, I'll give you a heads up, we'll do a icebreaker. We're going to do three, five, five. Is that right? I never lie.
Speaker 2: Are we able to start with this group? Literally, I was listening and not listening. That's all right. Is that possible.
Speaker 1: Listening but not listening? Definitely. There's one truth and one lie in there. I know, that's like, if I had a kid that said that to me, how would I, with my child's death, what would I say? Be more precise with your words, which I think, Andy, you're very precise with your words. Like, listening but not comprehending. Well, it's like I meant what I said. Even though I can't stand behind everything. When I haven't had kids, I'm pretty good at multitasking, but I didn't know until I had kids. I could literally read a whole kid's book and think about something else the entire time.
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
Speaker 1: That's crazy. That shouldn't be possible. But I didn't remember anything I read. And they were asking questions about it, and I'm like, I don't know. What do you think.
Speaker 5: What do you think? What do you remember? Dad, this story's about listening. Oh, shoot.
Speaker 6: I was going to avoid the blue wall because it pulls off.
Speaker 2: Oh, don't worry about it. Listen, if there's anything that I want to be known for, it's doing something. And that's where we had to repaint the wall.
Speaker 5: This has actually been repainted many, many times.
Speaker 2: I was expecting it to be because I tripped or something.
Speaker 5: It used to be orange for a while.
Speaker 7: Yeah, it just was. We're going to take a little bit of a walk down the road. It's a story. Brandon did teal for two hours. That was pretty strange. Someone just decided teal was the right choice.
Speaker 3: I gave Amy a hard time about the color. She says, yeah, they're impossible. All purses.
Speaker 5: They're like, huh.
Speaker 7: I didn't even get to serve at any of these.
Speaker 3: I made the knucklehead move. I walked out of the house last night without grabbing my bowl. I'm negotiating trying to get my doc to send me five. I did a couple.
Speaker 3: Paul had confirmed Mark was a tentative, but he's pretty much tied up in the audit all week this week. And then Sam, they'll be here at 11 yet, so we can start with what we got.
Speaker 2: So this day is kind of a big day, part of a big week, part of a big project. It's going to be awesome. And we wanted to get started with some things that help us build the perspective, both that we communicate from, help us understand what you say, what you mean, and all that other stuff. So I know that you guys, or I've at least heard that you guys use working genius, and that's kind of fun. I have done, I love personality type indicators, thinking type, they're all fun.
Speaker 2: They're all fun. Whenever I bring it to someone, they usually have one or two, one of two or three different responses. They've never heard of it, or don't box me in, which tells me everything I need to know already, so thank you. Or, ooh, this is really exciting, right? And what I always tell people is, whether we're measuring, whether we're trying to categorize how you think, behave, your personality, whatever word it is, it's never your prison. It is always just an opportunity for us to ask more detailed questions or better understand each other's perspectives.
Speaker 2: So, whatever experience you have with it, this is meant to be mostly fun, but fun in a way that means that people will tease you, right? I'm going to start off by teasing mostly Nate. Thank you. And as I see other people feeling. Comfortable.
Speaker 5: We don't have any tissues, so.
Speaker 2: well I am NOT one of the TJ's that Steve brought up so I'm not a total jerk I don't know what the other I'm like I think I'm a TP what is that totally playful sometimes pathetic whatever forward so if you guys what I want to do first is this is really valuable I think it helps us do a couple things one is talk about us because your perspective actually matters and what we're talking.
Speaker 2: about helps you get out of your seat because this hasn't meant to be you know staring at our computers and doing things it's meant to be interactive we are going to get more value for the rest of the day if you feel comfortable saying from my perspective I see this you'll see that that's actually a method to us getting good information and sometimes it'll help me to point at you if I think we're stalling and I need somebody to wonder more or if I think that we're not staying, focused and I will need us to be more I know that's what I mean I was like help.
Speaker 2: me tonight okay so what I would like you to do is yeah pick a color pick green for everybody get a green and put your down what's your name I guess we need a couple and writing nobody here's my glasses.
Speaker 2: oh yeah. I what we can we can make our guests and we'll see if we can get speed, get access to the assessment, the powers that be. I don't know what the rule is if you don't take it until after you've read the book.
Speaker 5: I think you're supposed to take it before you read the book.
Speaker 2: Okay, well, we'll have to talk to whoever is in... Yeah, it's only $25. I just looked it up. Well, yeah, the blocks, I'm pretty sure they can send it all out.
Speaker 8: Yeah, it should have already been sent out, too, actually.
Speaker 2: All right, well, maybe we'll guess at you, and then we'll move it once we actually get it. But here's what I'd like you to do. I'd like you to go put your group there when you go, and then... So put your name on the sticker. Name on the sticker, on two stickies, because you have your two geniuses. I'm not going to have your frustrations there. I get that those exist, but... They don't matter to me. But they're not... I'm not asking you to, like, work for six months on something in this. I just want to know what your geniuses are. You're not going to be forced into your frustration, at least not for such an extended period of time that it's going to make you quit your job.
Speaker 2: But I would also love if you shared either something in particular, like when you learned about this, what an aha moment. Or some sort of like, oh wow, that makes sort of sense. Or if you have another piece of information from a different personality type indicator that would be useful or interesting to be like, oh, now I know that and that. I want you to get comfortable hearing your own voice. Can we talk about that? Let me just write our name. Yeah, just write your name, put it on here, click this and this, and then one additional piece.
Speaker 2: of information that helps us hear your voice. Oh, right there. No, no, no, just say it. You can be our example. We're just gonna read this right. I'm not grading you, I mean, I am grading you, but I gotta wait until I get the transcript that needs to. What? Tell them. So you did that, so now, you tell us one thing about either that or a related personality type. Personality, you're like, oh, I learned this, but then I really like this, so.
Speaker 6: Oh, no, no, I don't, I'll just stick with it. Wondering was interesting for me because I ask a lot of questions. And typically, yeah, anyway, so I didn't even know that this was a bucket. I've never really done a lot of these things before. It made me take it a year ago. But then, yeah, it made a lot of sense when I did that. And then invention to me is just like there's always a better way. I'm just like, anytime I'm in a circle of people, I feel like I'm an outsider.
Speaker 6: We can always do this better. And the same thing is with questions. I ask a lot of questions that are, like, more open-ended, more just like, why did you do that? Less of, like, so questions. Have you ever actually gotten anything done, or do you just continue for one day? No, yeah. We decided on it.
Speaker 1: And then I pass it on to these people. Just make them figure it out. The observation I would have is you have your strengths, but you also get stuff done too.
Speaker 6: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: Meaning it's good to see how we rub off on each other.
Speaker 6: Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's just small business, though. You don't have the ability to, like, pass it off to someone.
Speaker 3: unless we're always next so are these what we wish to what roles we wish to play or that we.
Speaker 2: well these are uh when you read the book you'll notice these are sort of the natural tendencies of how our brain operates or what part of that project we tend to thrive in isn't it good you're.
Speaker 5: good at it and you love it essentially yeah you can do like 90 of the time and not feel burned.
Speaker 6: yeah it's energy giving yeah yeah so this is pretty much the i learned to get.
Speaker 8: done person um and making sure that everybody on my team also gets it done i'm also an enneagram eight for any of you um so that's kind of my other personality but yeah definitely very much attention to detail like ending a task to the finish line if something is left undone.
Speaker 1: Is there anything in our contract you can say? You may not have her! The challenge to me is the difference between wholehearted and obsessed. Because I even convince my bar when something's being done and it's higher than most which means the client might say, that's great.
Speaker 6: But it's not perfect.
Speaker 1: It's gotta be perfect for all these scenarios that I invent. Or it actually goes. Tuning this right into the super power that if gone awry can be costly. But I'm the one sticking it and I just finished that last launch because of that small launch. When you asked me when I was 12 or 13 I said I wanted to be an engineer. What I learned from this test personally is I wouldn't say that like I would say this for me at least I think it's changed over the years.
Speaker 1: and in the environments that I'm in I know it's probably not supposed to but I grew up in a family of 12 where you serve the role that needs to be. playing this role. But when I took this test, I came out horrible at this role. Part of that's because I'm used to, well, yeah, we can't do this. We gotta do this today. And then today becomes tomorrow. Like, my life is this now. But I love getting back to this. And I think being around Jake reminds me how much I love that idea of blue sky. Like, what if this was possible? There were no constraints. Nice.
Speaker 2: Steve's self-assessing.
Speaker 3: Guessing what's in the buckets. He's self-assessing. I like this. And this is a naveler. Navel man, yeah, a naveler. I'd like to see that is working behind the scenes. I've done that my whole career. The other is discernment. I like to ask a lot of questions.
Speaker 5: Allie and I work really together. We're getting this done. Nasty. We're getting this done. I came from a family of seven kids. I was the second oldest. And I also like checking things up, making a list, checking them off.
Speaker 1: It actually is an endorphin rush.
Speaker 5: It is. I don't get them done. I sit in the bathroom all night. I'm also a person who will step in where I love to make things happen. Supporting people is really big for me. That's why enablement works really well. I like projects or anything. Hearing all the decisions get made and then I make them happen.
Speaker 5: For me, I love doing that. It's my second one, but when I get to just sit down, deadlines for me are really good. I love being able to teach people and work with other people and just making their everyday, whatever it is, better. And so sourcing vendors, our internal teams, hear it all out. Love it.
Speaker 1: One thing I learned from myself, at least, is checklists are so critical. I do not check it off until it's really done. And I've seen people take a shortcut, and then it's not done. You think it's launched, but don't do that. Wait for that rush, and you've earned it. Yeah. And I thought about it, and I'm done thinking about it. It's got to be really done.
Speaker 7: I think that's the other is that factor to it which kind of drives you into a certain point how big projects type a let's get it done let's do it let's but then my second one is the discernment side which I always like to think about this kind of like filtered wonder you know it's kind of like you can't go quite as broad here but we're kind of like okay how can we poke so many holes in this thing and figure out what's the best so, I think I used to look at discernment more from a negative side I think I've always known about it about myself like more of a like an obsessive and like nebotical and I always look at that from like a value perspective like oh this is really great to bring to a team because it slows things down sometimes but I think as I've matured in an understanding that the way you poke holes into things and see things from different angles ultimately gives you a better aim yeah and so that's something that I actually really find that has been really useful for me in my career.
Speaker 7: in my personal life too. That's me.
Speaker 2: Alright, any guesses.
Speaker 1: And galvanizer? I thought that too, what do you say.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so discernment, which, sometimes leads me to believe that I don't need to understand anything to get it better. Which is, but it's true that I think that, sometimes. It's like I'm willing to take pretty big risks, betting that I'll figure it out. And saying like, I'm really confident this is the right direction. We're gonna get it if we go this way. I actually.
Speaker 2: really like, Jake helps me pause and Nate helps me measure the cost of taking jumps and so that teamwork. I actually really like that Jake and I sit, Because to me, this is really our whole ethos, which is that we can make something, and then we enjoy and we want to do that, and then we come with different levels of the project where we work together and make that happen. I think it's cool seeing that there's a lot of tenacity here, because it seems like that's sort of.
Speaker 2: the bread and butter of the block system. It's like, we get things done, whether we're the engineer out in the field, putting this back to, bring this back to life, or we're bringing you the thing. That's probably been today. Cool, fun. Anybody else observe anything about this before we move on? We'll have new people, we'll have to take it, we'll see how, I actually think when you put those on there,
Speaker 2: it's like, ah, that makes a lot of sense. And we can have the other people join us, and we'll make them use a different color to show that they weren't here.
Speaker 5: i think i had emily's because she had us do it in 2023 i think no we didn't yeah and then when she came on we didn't see any well we've been doing it a lot as an eight also i'm glad that i take.
Speaker 2: over this room so the intensity here we will not sam and i are type ones so not let it happen.
Speaker 1: uh you guys are nevermind i'll just let you guys try and i'll just do different things, that's right all right so here's the next thing i want to do and i did an awesome job.
Speaker 2: tearing this out i'm sure there's a better way to do that than what i just did but uh here's a this, This is still, we're in kind of an opening perspective. I want to get to your expertise, but I need us to see a bigger picture more clearly so that we can point it. And I think that this is the way that I think we can get here. Here's where it is.
Speaker 2: Somebody give me their favorite part that you guys...
Speaker 8: An OEC whisp.
Speaker 2: OEC what.
Speaker 8: Whisp. Can I have it? O-E-C-W-I-S-P. W-I-S-P. It's for a C-arm.
Speaker 3: Is that an easy part number? A part number off the top of your head? You can find it easily. No, I'm just curious. I'm just looking for that part number. Don't hold it.
Speaker 8: It's just what pops in my head.
Speaker 2: I want to, I'll probably have to, I think we're going to use sticky notes for this, but this is, a lot of times we're going to talk about the experience of a person, the software that they're using, or the company that they represent. But at the end of the day, star of the show is the part that really tells the story. And I want to use this to kind of build out both the technology, the teams, and the leadership that this project is representing, influencing. Does that make sense?
Speaker 2: So, what I would love to do is, I don't know that this matters as much about color coordination, because we're just going to map this out once so we can do some more colors. But the first level that I want to... do is when a part comes in what where how can you what screen shows you that.
Speaker 2: that part exists so when a part comes into the warehouse comes into the block ecosystem okay so we have a part in stock sure how does anybody within block look at a part on a screen and what like if there is a piece of software I have some assumptions about what that is but if there's a piece of software screen that's telling you that this part that this OEC wisp exists yeah what is the software that's telling you that I believe that there are at least three.
Speaker 2: pieces of software that independently could look all of the same part at a different time so I want you to either confirm that or do that and we will do another level, so we're going to start like right kind of close to this and then we'll look at what that software, what teams touch that software and we'll look at what yeah we'll see where it goes because i don't know exactly but this is kind of like reverse org chart you know rather than saying oh well jason's in charge of this or josh is in charge of this and these are the people that report to him and these.
Speaker 2: are the teams that report to them and then this is the software that they use and they're going to look at the part well that's a really long time before we get to the thing that we're actually going to be spending all of our time with and make sure it moves well so i want to start from the part say tell me one person who if any of you guys when's the last time you looked at this part.
Speaker 8: every single day what it was what software did you use uh my team primarily just uses salesforce.
Speaker 2: salesforce perfect so that's do you guys have a code name for it, salesforce 360. okay do you guys like to say sf360 yeah that's primarily everything, All right, so if there is this, if this exists in block, then one of the things we're going to do is connect to it. We're going to see it in Salesforce 365.
Speaker 1: Just practice, what is this part? Oh, yeah, sure.
Speaker 5: It's a wireless relay. It's an internet provider. It helps the hospital connect to the network.
Speaker 8: I think it goes on the cart.
Speaker 2: Okay, so that was the example. I did the first one for you. You guys are responsible for your own sticking, you know, pressing. Can you, one elder, if that part exists in blocks. you before it owns it when it owns it or doing it what is the other what are other technical systems that social and approach 2.0 okay we don't have it which.
Speaker 3: is rare yeah it is right we're also just playing with that part availability within within sources and that George with W message all managed yeah yeah.
Speaker 2: yeah that's what we're gonna do is we're gonna try to understand which teams use each of these but I want to just get you're gonna look at this part so it, sounds like we're out of the warehouse management yeah warehouse management is.
Speaker 7: all through Salesforce as well there's a go is that just a slice of they have their own application within it but yeah essentially like all inventory movement, and allocation of a condition and things like that. They have that response. I think it's a pretty particular within Salesforce that they're using that for.
Speaker 2: So I don't wanna miss this just by being overly fun process, but what is, so you're saying the warehouse management team or that department? That's a software. It's a software or is it Salesforce? It's within Salesforce. I think it's, yeah, Salesforce is.
Speaker 7: Yeah, it's like an application within Salesforce. That's where it is right now.
Speaker 1: I think they've built a lot of things on top of it.
Speaker 8: They did. Yeah, pretty much. So there's like different apps within Salesforce depending on what.
Speaker 2: So what would you call that one in particular.
Speaker 7: I know that a lot of that team operates out of BI logistics.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's what it's called.
Speaker 7: I think Ben might have access to a different warehouse one specifically. There is a BI warehouse, but I think that's more on the equipment side. So yeah, BI logistics. it's really about management it's a great question so this is there I want.
Speaker 2: to is there any other independent parts so let's not dive get into this so say a sourcing window probe but also just regular sourcing window we have this.
Speaker 3: right no because sourcing window is vendor-based they would not be they.
Speaker 8: wouldn't see our we would be looking like if we didn't have this in stock going to them to find it but they can't see our our vendors can't see our point.
Speaker 2: would you ever would you go to sourcing window let's pretend you didn't have one, then yes then good would go you would go there before you had it and you said this is how I'll find it so I can get it okay I still want I do want yeah the, journey to becoming a block part is a multiple.
Speaker 6: Same thing with, like, if somebody orders it, how, is it the warehouse management software is how the team then knows to pick the part.
Speaker 7: Yeah. Okay. It would be the same. And very similar when we were procuring it, whether that be for stock or for purchasing from a vendor as well.
Speaker 1: You guys, break number two into a little image for this one. Oh, nice.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I was thinking about our website, but that's not, I mean, we first have to have it in our stock for it to show up on there.
Speaker 2: That's okay.
Speaker 8: No. No, it doesn't. No. Anything and everything is on our website, so.
Speaker 2: That matters to me, so I'm making everybody get up. I'm not going to, or else I'm going to lose the power of this.
Speaker 6: Do you guys add your own, like, images? a sticker too or is that like it's all watermarked but those are all ours oh it's just a watermark.
Speaker 9: we watermark them because it was a differentiator for us if you have a photo got it amy's github.
Speaker 3: has any inventory does github have kind of sign github hubspot have any inventory no all of it.
Speaker 9: was in salesforce and it's connected to so hubspot just takes the information salesforce is there any.
Speaker 2: other software screen that you would use to see i will turn the gravity off, time there's no other software screen that you would say where you'd see this part as.
Speaker 5: a block employee somewhere i mean i don't know if accounting still uses sap.
Speaker 2: Not for inventory. Okay. Can we use, since we used green for this, we'll say green are the software systems. Can we say blue are the teams? Can you? I have a blue one. I don't, this is where we are absolutely, not totally, but we're, so we absolutely, what teams touch these software systems.
Speaker 6: What person uses these? Yeah, there's gotta be a ton, right? Your mom starts to. Amy doesn't like pop.
Speaker 8: I'm just kidding. Yeah. The parts team would be, well, the parts team uses all of those except for the logistics.
Speaker 6: That's fine. We can throw away a sticky note if you guys are right about it.
Speaker 9: One thing to know about the website, though, is the website does not have . We used to have a maximum of 10,000 cards, but there is a tab in sales force that says whether or not the set of equipment .
Speaker 6: Do you prefer to show it as in stock or what do you mean.
Speaker 8: The procurement team would pretty much be in control. They don't use the website. So, what do you mean by that? They don't use the website.
Speaker 6: So, what do you mean by that.
Speaker 9: Yeah, here, over here. You can, yeah. .
Speaker 1: And this is a brand new park.
Speaker 9: Are we going to know what's in the challenge with sourcing the bill?
Speaker 9: Do you know how many different parts flow through sourcing window, like is it a thousand different parts out of the 40,000 that all of them, no, but how many, how many different parts do people buy through sourcing window.
Speaker 1: Like actually buy. Not just because you have a select star you need from those, like looking at actual orders instead of what's in the, like what's in the list. Do you need to ask my date again? Yeah.
Speaker 1: You gotta have a key somewhere though. I'm repair, that's where we have Jay for, he's the legend.
Speaker 6: I am the legend. That's where they hired me.
Speaker 9: You know you're making a chute, should we use it.
Speaker 1: I never said that. No, no, no, don't. You need some. Architecturally, that is the question. We actually had that conversation.
Speaker 9: That's actually how Sam ended up working on my team originally. I was like, guys, hammer, see hammers. And then suddenly Sam came to my team.
Speaker 1: Because there's a significant difference between, we build it the way it's usually best to do, or not. It's not a huge thing to migrate from one to the other, but that's why you do it.
Speaker 9: From a marketing perspective, I don't want to be dividing.
Speaker 6: Yeah, ooh. Yeah, so that if someone is at first, and it shouldn't be blocked, if you need that part for your service, you should probably get dibs over that, over someone.
Speaker 6: Okay, can somebody walk us through what those stickies are? I don't know. Somebody do it.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God. Wow. Get out of the way. We need to take a picture.
Speaker 8: Let's look at one of those crime diagrams. I figured out who the serial is. Yeah, I guess so in type, like I guess specifically. So you would have your component repair team. So if we get one in or it gets to, actually, the harvest team is who pulls one from a system. So if we get a CRM in, there's a WISP on it, then they're going to actually harvest it and bring it into inventory. And they're mainly using Salesforce 360 and the logistics app within that.
Speaker 8: to bring it to stock. All of our parts that we're able to then test or then would go to before putting on the shelf would go through component repair. So we have our internal component repair team. So basically it would move into what's like a TO or technical or for that team to repair it, refurbish it, if it needs to be painted. anything like once that's complete it would then be the inventory team again.
Speaker 8: with the harvesting that would bring it into good stock at that point all of the like parts team procurement team and services would be able to see that that part is in stock and finished goods would also show up for like our external customers that might be looking for a whisk at that point it becomes visible to all of them and those all of the sales team pretty much all of this.
Speaker 8: except for of it so let's say we have one in stock then either like my team is, quoting it from our stock to either customers that are in our customers that come through up site ask so then all the software same day like the procurement team, They're finding parts for service contracts, so they're just trying to find it and selling. They're finding an option, same with like service, but if we don't have it, we're trying to find it.
Speaker 8: Once we set, that's when any of these sales teams would process an order in Salesforce 360 and creates a note. It would go then to the outbound shipping team, which they're then using Salesforce and the logistics app. Take it out of stock, make labels, shipping documents, pack it up, get it out the door, add tracking. So then our customer information, for any reason, if that part or when a core comes back, that would then go to the outbound team and the returns team.
Speaker 8: So there again, Salesforce 360. process the return to credit back the customer, or to get a exchange part, so their non-functioning part back. And if it's a non-functioning part exchange, and that starts all over again, where we can use that non-functioning part and possibly repair it, so it goes through this entire loop again. Or if they claim that it rivals the same thing, it would be like the returns, again, to test it. That's where then the returns team and I get involved, invoice, put stuff back.
Speaker 8: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Is this where you're supposed to go to not present our reports? No, that's true. That was, this whole thing was all about that. Oh, Tom.
Speaker 6: What's the unique identifier, for going through that whole system that you just, did you mention all the different loops that that same part, do you have a unique identifier.
Speaker 5: Yeah, so everything has a serial number on it for that manufacturer's serial number.
Speaker 8: not a serial number we give it. Well, some parts we have to give it its own serial number if it doesn't have a manufacturer one. But yeah, everything, that's in the inventory detail of the part, which that's all managed through the logistics part. So when the harvest team brings it into stock, they're adding a serial number, a data manufacturer if it's applicable to that, if it's refurbished or tested. So then all the sales teams have that information to be a quote. Slightly different prices sometimes or when these two are across the board field.
Speaker 2: That was excellent. I think we may try to pull that into like a picture that we can rest for us and we may add some. layers. But I wasn't thinking about spatial. My wife will tell you, she has me pick the Tupperware. I've never picked in my life the right Tupperware. Not one time, she's like, okay, so this is, don't tell her this happened.
Speaker 2: It's not bad. Well, because the next thing we were going to talk about is, I wanted to kind of filter it to some humans so that we could talk about who owns this process. Because there's a handful of things that, while it seems like we don't touch that in terms of the functionality from a technical side, oh, that's not sourcing window or sourcing windows pros scope. It is still, it doesn't mean we wouldn't want to recognize that there are multiple lines where people have to use this software and this software.
Speaker 2: We want to know, well, what are they used to? What are they expecting? How different would we make it if we were to make it? without thinking. So there's just a lot of questions or pathways to getting answers that allow us to think more thoughtfully and comprehensively about what it is that we're doing. So for most of this, and the other part is, we're basically, the rest of this phase, we're thinking a lot more from a human perspective. And so extending from the part to the software to.
Speaker 2: the human, and then deep diving into humans, that's sort of the other brain. Oh, who is the person? Because sometimes you're going to be representing personal experience of that human. Sometimes it's going to be like, oh, I've watched it. We're going to be having you say things like, when you tell us that this thing or somebody is responsible for this, or something needs to happen, who is it that would do this? Or do you expect it to be automated or triggered by some other event? Does that make sense? Cool. Before.
Speaker 2: we do, somebody can... that doesn't have their name on the road to success. Amy. I love the fact that we're doing this. We're just not afraid of making mistakes here.
Speaker 8: Your mind's Amy of her last all-time game.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So what we did was obviously put them up there. And then we told something, whether it was. I'm sorry. Why do you have to flip the window? I want to take a picture of that. Yeah, can we link that up with the? I have a couple follow-ups, though. We should have had her use it as a microphone. So you don't just put yourself up there. You also tell us either some aha moment or some personality-type indicator that you think tells us everything we need to know about you.
Speaker 9: Like why the moment that I realized that, yes.
Speaker 2: Well, it could be that. It's really open-ended.
Speaker 6: Not another one. Woo woo. Oh, no. We got a lot of them. She wonders and she gets stuck.
Speaker 9: I put W. So I would. and then I thought about my process for choosing for my house and I am that person that will like dream it up and be like this is the vision and then I immediately run to the paint store and buy the paint and slap it on the wall and I'm like shoot that's not the right tone like that's not exactly what I wanted because I like to just skip the middle and then when I went through this process with my team they were like oh my gosh so much makes sense because so many team meetings you run I have whiplash when I listen because it's like dream do dream do.
Speaker 2: We are now even more tenacious than we were before and even more prone to distraction. I told everybody I was going to make a few jokes. Jake what were some of your follow up questions? You mentioned when you were walking us through this parts team versus procurement. What's the difference? Those probably mean something to you guys to me that I was lost.
Speaker 8: So procurement, so Block has service contracts, like with Siemens, since we were acquired by Siemens, and we have a team.
Speaker 2: Pause. I'm going to have to dig into certain things. So a service contract is a commitment to service their big machines with your field, source, site, field, service, service engineers. So part of the arrangement is that you have people that are now responsible for going and fixing them. Which then need part of the service contract.
Speaker 8: Yes. So if one of these systems needs parts, so an example would be like Oklahoma University Health is one of the big Siemens. We have a procurement team that finds parts specifically for those contracts.
Speaker 6: And that's all they do. That's all they do.
Speaker 8: Yeah, that's literally all they do. And so they're literally just trying to either, they're either shipping it from our inventory to just get it out. or they're just literally procuring it from one of the hundred some vendors in from the sourcing window to try and find an option my team the parts team is for like every other customer who doesn't have a contract who just needs a part then whether that's through with common common spirit which uses our tool or whether that brothel which is another big asset management hospital group who.
Speaker 8: doesn't use our tool my team which is 10 CSRs is trying to find either sell that like so we're actually quoting and like to get them to buy from us the procurement team just needs to find it and get it out the door so they're not trying to sell to make money my team is actually trying to sell to make money because all the money for their team is in the service contract itself so my team would be for all those other customers that don't have service contracts we're finding parts for them and either selling them from our stock or using sourcing window to find it from one of our vendors.
Speaker 8: to try and find a part for them. but these aren't large.
Speaker 6: enough customers that they would then use themselves that's not happening no.
Speaker 8: we don't want to they don't want there's either they're either not big enough we have about a 30% base of international customers and we haven't quite there's only only have one Canada that uses sourcing window right now and then but yeah it's like for instance of GE MBS is a huge customer of ours but they have an entire procurement team to find parts for them so that would kind of for them defeat the purpose of having that team to themselves to be able to source their.
Speaker 6: own so why it's easier from one of the email you yeah you deal with it right.
Speaker 8: yes so so that's the difference is my team is actually selling to make money I think that's on part so the procurement team is just fulfilling service they're.
Speaker 6: trying to cut costs they want the lower cost yes but probably also fastest yes.
Speaker 3: they're different real clear we have the buy sell on the side, sell side and where the overlap is is that when we do not have it in stock before we do not have it stock to buy or stock to sell we both use sourcing window to then go and locate those parks and in some can and you'll find also they'll use sourcing window they'll send an email and they'll also send and also.
Speaker 2: call folks to supplement vendors more charts so when a part has the potentially with all of its potential revenue shelf generating in theory there, could be the block there could be the parts there could be somebody sourcing.
Speaker 2: window, that all did at the same time. Like, let's say the same four hour, because maybe there's only one part on block premises, maybe it just happened. Is that true.
Speaker 8: Looking for the exact same part for different sites.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yes. Like a procurement, a block procurement person, a block parts person, and then some other external client who's using sourcing with their pro. They could all try to look at the same part. You guys ever run into issues with that? Yes.
Speaker 9: And there are parts in our inventory that we won't sell because we have them. So many of the service contracts will say, you have to have this tube or this thing in stock ready to go all the time. Like contractually, we're obligated. And then my team wouldn't be able to sell those. Insurance need to have a certain amount of capital. You guys have to have a certain amount. Like high failure parts. Then just for profit, I also think we are trying to identify. parts might be for we just took on this pool of equipment and so we think we're going to need.
Speaker 2: these types of parts and so out right does that well mark or do people yeah yeah and that's that's.
Speaker 7: um communicated through a inventory status so there's there's finished goods and available and then there's also i think it's still a finished goods service hold so the differentiating factor.
Speaker 2: is within the inventory itself right yeah so is that uh i don't want to dig in here for a minute but i know jake before we go online is that something someone is responsible for every time we've entered into salesforce or is that a part of the setting that this part is something you can.
Speaker 8: just put in the service right who puts it in service holders that would be like that would be ben and paul that make those decisions all year and then yeah based on the time.
Speaker 5: So we have like a inventory management team that will, as soon as that part comes in, we decide where that part goes based on the set of priorities.
Speaker 2: That's not an individual part. It's not like a blanket for this SKU.
Speaker 9: No. Because you might just have to have two of those on a whole, but we have five total so we can sell.
Speaker 2: But that's manually operated with a rules engine.
Speaker 8: It's manually operated. It's actually like with tubes and detectors, which are going to be like the more higher end fill and more expensive parts on systems. So like for OU, we have a lot of like seam and seamer contracts. We have to consistently have certain Stratton tubes, and they usually will want them to be a newer data manufacturer. Because just like tubes are like cars, they depreciate with like usage manufacturer. So if you have a contract, we're going to want to have a contract.
Speaker 8: something like newer on hold instead of like the 1998 high usage tube. So there's like certain things. So if someone comes in asking for a Stratton Z, I may see that we have two really nice ones, but I see that they're on service hold. So the only way my team is allowed to quote those is if we ask like Paul Beard or something to be like, hey so-and-so is looking for this, can we actually swing taking one out of service? The answer is usually no, but sometimes every once in a while we make a mistake.
Speaker 2: Whenever we find one brain being the source of permission, the hinge, it's just something we mark down and go like this.
Speaker 5: A lot of questions that you had of the, what did you say, tribal knowledge, so much of that is in Paul Beard's.
Speaker 2: brain and the park's team brain so would you say that as a secondary part this is the cue to know that i'm about to say something ridiculous is it more important that we use llms to extract just his decision-making capacity and clone just the decision-making capacity not how much he loves his kids or anything like that just that would be extremely helpful but a lot of scope for this project that's true everywhere okay yeah cool i don't know that's good i like i that is a general.
Speaker 2: rule of thumb is we try not to go on deep rabbit holes about of scope problems but you've got to let us see some of those things because it helps us understand how you think about, and some of the other just hurdles you navigate as a team so it doesn't mean we're going to get distracted by it later on but it helps us say oh okay this is something that they think about this is a user we have to think about this is a because i'm sure paul uses this other one too and we're going to want to think about his input because he has other roles in this does that make sense.
Speaker 6: can we finish by summarizing yeah of because again sourcing window and sourcing window pros with and if we look at these what are the main pieces of or teams or software that are, and it's the external vendors the external customers or buyers and the parts team and.
Speaker 2: is that pretty much it yeah does somebody want to take a marker and star the ones that that are the most prominent touchers of no and yeah you can start at that point.
Speaker 6: And then if you had to say from the end so two of those are external two or three of those that are internal Yeah, who are the main users who use this like.
Speaker 5: Internally the procurement uses it more than you guys do really, Because of all the server this side of it. Yes procurement doesn't use this.
Speaker 6: And can I say is this just clicked in my head now? Which is probably probably for it to click but sourcing window Pro is your guys's inventory that you're selling sourcing window is vendor only use it and.
Speaker 5: Because SWP also uses sourcing window. It's like it's like two. Sourcing Window Pro actually stands for procurement, which is where an external customer is putting in a request to the Sourcing Window vendor. On the block side, we are the external customer using Sourcing Window to find our part.
Speaker 6: And then, sorry, I think I chopped you off. Which of those teams do you say, so it sounds like procurement.
Speaker 8: The parts team is the only one that uses Sourcing, or Sourcing Window Pro. Because we're the ones that interact with those external customers that use our tool. So no other internal team.
Speaker 6: Got it.
Speaker 8: For Sourcing Window, then that's going to be, yeah, parts procurement and then service for any time any of those teams need to source a part that we. And then what Vicki said, Sourcing Window Pro customers.
Speaker 5: We should probably also do Align Internal Customers to SW. Because I mean, they're technically...
Speaker 7: Could you put a star on as well.
Speaker 6: So which one, to SW or SWP.
Speaker 7: For SW, so the returns team will do a lot of negotiation communication through sourcing window for things that are coming late out of terms and conditions and things like that. So we do a lot of vendor interfacing. So you jump on EMA, where is it? Yeah, well, it's jumping in there and saying, like, hey, this is coming late, or can we get an extension, or those types of things. Yeah. Yeah, that's a real point.
Speaker 2: I was missing it, but I was writing something down. Which one do you use? The returns team.
Speaker 7: Returns team. You use SW.
Speaker 6: Yep, the vendor side. Vendor side. Got it. All right. Cool. We good.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, good. Thank you. I want to, is this a working, is this a soon-to-be distraction? Because then I'll just, I'll wrap up.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, you're probably kind of, you're doing it right. Don't give him power, Lenny.
Speaker 2: This is what it is in my house, too. Not true. Okay, well, okay, this was a good, this was a great warm-up. If you guys remember last week, we talked about, at the end, the kickoff. The goal of this week is to dive into all these things. I wanted to, Nate's screaming. And this is things related to a park.
Speaker 2: The rest of this time, we're going to be thinking related to people. people want to accomplish, how difficult it is, how many systems they need to touch besides the one that we're actually looking at, all of that sort of stuff. So the one thing that I want, you guys have been great, and I want to continue the high, participation. And so one of the things that we're going to do is we'll all have one visual reference to be able to look at, and the goal is we made some kind of assumptions based on everything.
Speaker 2: we've learned, everything we've seen, everything we've written down so far, and we don't expect them to be right. That wasn't the goal, was to get it right. The goal was to get it into something that you could disagree with. So you guys said, oh, it's not quite like that, right, to build out more there. Over that time, there's going to be a combination of factual things that we need to get right. We're still, it takes a while for us to ramp up on our own. Like I knew what you meant when you said service contract.
Speaker 2: I just needed to slow down because it's not quite as ingrained yet. I was like, oh yeah, that means, I know what that means, but then by the time I lose the next 30 words you say, right? So we're gonna do that the best we can, but some of it's gonna be factual. Some of it's gonna be workflow. Some of it's going to be telling us about humans that are or aren't here. All of that's gonna be useful. Some of it's gonna be about things that should be, things that were said, things that we'd like it to be, and some things are gonna be future. None of those are off limits right now. The bigger the picture that we can get,
Speaker 2: the better it helps us understand because what you actually want that you know is impossible right now might be the thing that clues our brain into what you're actually, oh, that's why that's, right? So we'll do our best to make sure that we're not meandering beyond where we have the capacity to get back on focus and get what we need done, but it is useful to hear you guys tell us. practical things, people-based things. Does that make sense? Cool.
Speaker 2: This is a good transition point.
Speaker 6: I guess we could eat.